today's guest is a business entrepreneur
in the food
realm and he started his deal
uh right in baton rouge his first
uh outlet his first food locale right
there in baton rouge louisiana
where i was attending school
and you know now he's built it into a
billion dollar industry
i'm grateful for his time today just to
learn about
what his ride has been like and what
he's learned and what we can learn from
him
uh today's guest is uh
the chicken finger champ from raising
canes it is mr
todd graves
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
todd graves how are you man well i'm
great i'm even better being up here with
you
yeah thanks man thanks so much for
coming in uh i uh
so your business now so raising canes is
it's a chicken finger company yeah
and how big is the business now now
we're pushing 600 locations
in almost 25 years of business so it
blows me away we're about to start
cranking about 100 a year
good locations man so wow blows me away
and do you have like a say on what
locations are approved or not or do you
have other people that do that well i
have a team
a great team that does it they work with
local brokers but i approve every site
everyone yeah um okay so that's where
it's at
now so then i want to go back to like so
you grew up in louisiana right
yeah yeah born in new orleans raised in
baton rouge oh nice where'd you go high
school at
uh episcopal high school in baton rouge
yeah my kids go there now my wife went
there so we're like
episcopal family or alumni huh yeah
alumni um
yeah i saw your son came out here with
you right now yeah yeah he's at his
exams later in the week and so
he had some time off so i like to bring
him uh when i'm doing business and be
around be exposed to it he's just 17 you
know but it's good to get that stuff in
his head
yeah is he a pretty decent kid oh great
kid man great kid you know plays
baseball makes a's you know just like
it's great his sister's older sister
twos at lsu and uh
good student too great they like to have
a good time but they keep it uh
they keep it good and that so it's been
easy raising them yeah
yeah yeah um was it did you start being
a dad like in the middle of well you
must have started being a dad in the
middle of your
company growing yeah yeah you know so
canes for me was a college
business plan you know and so i started
and opened up like i said almost 25
years ago that first location north
gates lsu
yeah i think i went in there man uh i
think i went in there probably
i mean i was probably high honestly
you're under the influence of something
which is okay
they still serve you yeah well yeah it
says that actually you get go get that
chicken man so that's good late night
man even hungover on sunday man it's uh
that's our bread and butter yeah yeah it
was good man uh
yeah so i guess and so then take me
through that so like
um there's like a lot of rumors out
there yeah you were a fisherman and you
got
you were doing fishing and so then what
happened like you're
yeah take me how you kind of started the
first one yeah you know
it's a college business planning class
so i grew up working in restaurants and
bars and
high school college and i was like the
kid that did the lemonade stand in the
neighborhood always entrepreneurial
right yeah so i wanted my own restaurant
okay but i'm a college student right so
i'm like i want to do something that
caters to the students i wanted to hire
students because i knew the work
environment they wanted uh i knew
college kids would work hard man they'll
bust their ass but they need some
somebody that cares about them let's
listen some fun music you know what's
what serve our customers make them feel
good about coming in and spending their
money with us
but let's have a good time when we do it
was one of the first restaurants that
actually had music going on in the
background things like that
but that was my vision and so for
business planning class i had a partner
then when i started and we wrote it for
his business plan class at lsu
got the worst grade in the class oh yeah
in there baby
in the hair yeah you know but that's
fuel right yeah that's exciting
especially
so so if you get that though do you feel
like like were you guys deterred was the
business
you were the partner at that point yeah
do you have a partner i did back then
he sold out after the second one he just
wasn't a he wasn't a fry cook cashier
didn't make him happy you know but i
love working drive-throughs i like
working fry lines you know it's what i
love
which is important i tell these students
now i'm like whatever you go into making
sure it's something you like to do
you're passionate about because if not
you won't be successful at it right and
if you love what you do works
comes down to a grind but if you love it
then you're always happy doing it
it wasn't the right business for him
we've stayed dear friends but he sold
after the second one but
we have those memories together because
worst grade in business planning class
and he's just a b minus he wasn't a hard
grader
but it was the worst grade in the class
but for me man it's like okay tell me
tell me i can't do it let me show you
i'm going to okay
okay so there you are so you guys get a
little bit of neglect there from the
grading system
and then what happens like um so then
where do you go from there yeah so i
thought you know we needed money to do a
spot right and so
i took that business plan look i thought
businessmen
you know needed to look the parts bought
a cheap suit right
oh yeah bought a briefcase from like
office depot the one with the little uh
brass locks on it you know like to look
official right
i'd go in like like a little bit some of
the locks they never even opened dude i
had one once it never
you couldn't even get in it they were so
cheap right yeah i had it on the
zero zero zero i'd crank it up bring up
the business plan
talk to him about this chicken finger
dream i had right banks were nice enough
but every one of them were like hey man
you know
you might want to work in the industry
for 10 years you might want to do this
and the other
you're not in a position for us to lend
you money once again no no no
makes you want to do it that much more
but had you had any experience in that
line of work at all i mean yeah
i've always worked in restaurants right
and did it and knew it like
i knew how much my aprons would cost you
know what i mean like i knew it so well
but
people had a problem back then of just a
chicken finger only concept
right because quick service this is what
happened to business plan they said you
didn't do your research because like
mcdonald's is adding all this variety
and all these different things you're
doing the opposite you want to do just
one thing these chicken finger meals and
it's not where your industry's going
but i knew doing one thing and doing
better to anybody else would always pay
off
okay and was there that option out there
at the time because i remember growing
up they had popeyes and that's turned
more into like a place where people
fight i feel like dj's it's more like a
boxing
it's almost like a mini ufc over there
sometimes
but um was there anything that was
serving just that chicken finger
yeah guthrie's they had started
guthrie's chicken versus started off in
auburn years
years before and they did uh university
of georgia they did
florida state and so the model was out
there this wasn't in louisiana right and
so it's hard for them to see that vision
and for me i just knew college kids like
good food and if you can do that chicken
finger meal like you said
and our busy biggest business business
was the late night business to start off
with and it went into the days
so i stayed i stayed true to it i knew i
could do it but this to me was like
this is my dream right so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna shut down i'm not gonna
stop i'm never gonna give up so
i got a job through a friend of a friend
working as a boilermaker in refineries
right to do turnaround shift work to
raise money okay so boilermaker what is
it
well so like when they when a refinery
needs one section to be
fixed right put into equipment replace
old stuff
they'll get a group of boiler makers to
go in and do all that grunt work okay
but they pay you big money because you
work long hours during the week and they
want that
section that refinery come back as soon
as possible because with the oil
production going
everything welding cutting trays out
putting in new equipment
i mean it's pretty much everything and
you have to learn it on the fly but it's
like they want that thing open as soon
as possible to get the oil production
going so you can make a ton of money if
you're willing to work hard
okay so you got down there so you're
working to or finally so how long after
you guys have this business plan
that you're able to put it together and
kind of get out to full two years
because after my refinery stent i needed
more money and i met a guy named wild
bill tolar no kidding everybody had
nicknames mine was hollywood
longer story oh dude we had a guy i
remember we started work used to work at
this summer camp and they had a guy who
would come down
and i shouldn't even work in there man i
was dating a girl and she got fired and
then i was like
they were like oh you can work here
right and so then
they had a guy would come and take
pictures of all the kids swimming and
stuff every day
and his name was wild bill right so
finally well one day i'm like
hey are we ever going to see those
pictures from wild bill and i'm like
they're like who's wild bill like the
photographer like
we don't have a photographer it was just
some guy
some random dudes i'm while building the
photographer yeah taking pictures of
kids swimming which was
a little not not ideal so wild bills can
be interesting yeah it can be this guy
was a
wild ass and uh he he earned his
nickname but he said look you don't you
don't mind working hard
and you're trying to raise money for
this chicken finger dream these bullet
makers were incredibly encouraging to me
like man you're going to open your
restaurant
while bilson has summer's commercial
fishing in alaska so were you running
around and saying like chicken fingers
chicken face i mean you were just
chirping about it yes man like you threw
my passion right i was on chicken finger
dream dude you know so it's like
everywhere and everything and so people
weren't just discouraging but they're
more like hey
you got a degree you know you should do
this you should do that maybe later in
life you will come back but
like i'm like no this is what i want to
do those boulder makers were the most
encouraging people i've seen along there
really
all of them like man you go for your
dreams they saw me working hard next to
them every day they're oh yeah out here
for your chicken fingers
and uh anyway and so while bill said
look you can you can cut it
go work go up to knack neck alaska and
get a job in bristol bay
gill netting for sakai if you want to
make some real money go up there and i
did
called a float plane to king salmon my
sister gave me her freaking flyer miles
flying to anchorage
got hit king salmon hitchhiked up to
knack neck went in tent city
took a month to get on a boat talking
the captain into it
that summer commercial fishing in alaska
is crazy what uh
so what was that time like up there like
are the wha are you working with like a
lot of
inuits are you working with like a lot
of just local
people like that are kind of hiding out
because it's almost like the like the
the icy key west i feel like alaska is
almost that strange kind of like
place where people can go to kind of get
like really get away
yeah yeah it's a mix so and you would
indians hold the permits right they're
the original boats so you have the inuit
population but a lot of fishermen from
washington you know oregon things like
that and they go up to spend the summer
to make money and uh
they're highly motivated because you can
make a ton of money most people just
work that summer
but then it was interesting because when
i got on the boat i realized how
motivated they are right
so there's like you can go out and
during the peak of the season
some are born in a stream right they
swim out to the ocean they're these
beautiful silver fish
all of them have a cycle between four
and like seven years
okay then they know to come back to the
original river up the same river they
spawn
and they die and it's the cycle it's
crazy yeah so when they're coming in
during the summer man
it's droves of fish and so it's like a
boomerang almost yeah man boom and boom
and so then we were fishing for sockeye
salmon the japanese were buying like 95
of it paying top dollar oh yeah and you
can't keep going out into the ocean
intercept these fish right you have a
lorraine line you couldn't cross so if
you set your
net on that line in front of another net
you just made like 10 times more money
right
so but is there a lot of jockeying for
position out total jockeying man
you picked you nailed it man so it's
like you will play chicken with other
boats because you want that better set
for your net and these captains are
motivated man we
ram boats boats ram dust my partner went
out with me then
his boat ram his captain rammed another
boat and sunk it out there man
some crazy stuff man people were dying
out there
all this stuff because you're working 20
hour days during the peak right and it's
not just four hours of sleep it's like
an hour here and there go take a nap
you're working so hard so people get
tired and then they they get
lazy they get not careful and they get
thrown out with the nets or whatever's
going on so
imagine a kid on a chicken finger dream
the back of this 36-foot boat
national geographic's going to film the
madness medical helicopters are taking
people out you're hearing so and so boat
just how to death and all this and
you're filling up the boat with fish
waves are crashing over the side you're
scared you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna crash you're gonna
you're gonna either get hit or you're
gonna sink when i was out there for that
chicken finger dream
dang it's almost like that's almost like
the ufc out there it sounds like the
ultimate fishing
champion championship or something like
yeah i can't even imagine people jocking
and and the the the hours that you're on
those boats like what's that kind of
time like the hours that you're on this
you just stay out
and so like you know time's money so if
you have to go into the dock
you know i mean you miss some money so
they have tender boats that you drop
your fish off to so you just live out
there you're staying on the boat
oh you're out there now and then the
little boats come by and you guys fill
and you guys will just fill them up with
fish
fill them up fish yeah you take a tinner
boat take your nets off boom put it back
in and you go right back at it now was
there any drug use or anything like that
on the boat because i could imagine some
people would be adderalled up or
something during it you know
back then you know adderall hadn't hit
it hit its stride you know so you just
you just work and your body just gets
conditioned to it man you become so hard
like
when i came back it was hard to get back
into society a little bit because you're
just like you have to just constantly
work
then it gets cold and it gets that you
get beat up and then like i came back i
was kind of like
man i don't i don't know if i've fit in
just that a couple weeks later i got
soft again you know yeah
but uh start using scope again yeah
exactly now so that's interesting so
what do you think about like
because that takes a certain type of
person you know to go
and do that type of work that type of
grueling environment where it's almost
like a
testament of your will in addition to
you having to be employed at the same
time yeah you're doing a job but you
also
have to have this internal kind of thing
going on where you were gonna hold the
line you were going to keep
going do you think that that was
something that was always with you even
as a child
like were you always just kind of like a
not a sucker for punishment but were you
always somebody that wanted to be like
in the fire or when you look back on
your youth do you see moments where
you kind of understand your behaviors
then and you still see them in yourself
now yeah you know a lot of it and so
i use sports as an example right and so
just playing something like football
right well what's on the football team i
was i mean look i went to 2a private
school so i've been like not like
working everybody plays
not like yeah everybody plays so it's
not like i'm saying i'm some great
athlete
right but like i wanted to be the leader
on the team right like i wanted to be
leader so i could have played receiver
or running back or whatever but i want
to be quarterback because i wanted to
man the offense and 2a football also
played on the defensive side
went to defensive end but i wanted to be
in charge and then i knew i could pull
the most out of everybody right so the
best thing about playing to a private
ball is
everybody plays you got to get the most
out of them so i knew how to motivate
them
versus chewing their ass it was like get
their faces we're going to do this man
we're going to do good
and i think those leadership things and
that hard work because i left everything
on the field
i also want to do well in school you
know and things like that so that
determination was always there and it
really paid off later
in a big way when i wanted to start this
dream right you know
right because yeah i guess now that's
something you notice in some people some
people are just good motivators you know
you feel like that's probably one of
your strongest suits yeah because look
man you know when i went
and worked in high school college and
restaurants it was more of a you're
doing wrong
i yelled at you you know and this
negative reinforcement doesn't work in
my business
if you go through raising cane you'll
see a bunch of happy smiling people but
they're going to crank out your food as
quick as they can
good quality but it comes from positive
motivational management look like
i go through my kitchens go see my crews
all over the country right but i go
through the kitchen hey that's nice
toast
right and you think telling a college
kid they're like yeah i'm just grilling
toast big deal they're like hey thanks
hey thanks for the hard work y'all
appreciate it hearing good things you're
doing here the community loves you
positive positive positive because look
it comes down to it's hard it's hard to
work long shifts in a restaurant right
but they know i care about them then
they work even harder right
we got a question that came in right
here actually um here we go right here
for you and this isn't live just so you
know
okay and you know what i'm gonna pour my
liquid death into a cane's cup for you
today you want to do that with me bro
i don't know drinking something called
liquid death but i trust you
yeah it's just water man i mean unless
you don't make it through this
it's a good water man they it's actually
a really good water but uh
it's good it's delicious it really is
man i don't know how they did it but
they did it somehow yeah that's
delicious i'm a big water guy by the way
so
that's good stuff me too well cheers
brother cheers
um yeah let's get to this question right
here here we go
hey todd hey theo uh just wanted to come
and ask a quick question i'm out of
raising kane 61 in monroe
and i wanted to share my favorite story
with todd was one time he came through
and bought a whole bunch of cookies for
everybody on staff and i always thought
that was such a nice thing to do
so i wanted to ask todd what is your
favorite memory
from raising canes would it be your
first store would it be somewhere else
would it be your time before as like a
boilermaker
sockeye salmon fishing uh what you got
gang gang
boom boom gang baby that's a good
question man and so
yeah do you have a favorite moment you
have any there could be many but you
have one that kind of stands out to you
or a sentimental moment something that
happened along the way
man you know i have so many of them and
here's the thing
when it's so hard to start something you
build a culture of appreciation
like every restaurant matters to me
every crew member matters to me
every box that goes out to every
customer matters to me and so
when you have this appreciation all
these moments so like going through
there and seeing a crew working hard i'm
like hey go get them some cookies
they're working hard do this thing is
and seeing them
care well he remembers that it's just
interesting i mean we you know we just
asked for any for submissions of
thoughts or questions so that
you know like uh it's just interesting
that that's what someone would send yeah
you know he remembered that moment right
and look he's going to carry that
other things he does throughout his life
and say look treat people well
and when you do that it comes back so
everything is just the evolution of it
and where we're going now and now be
able to do hundreds of locations a year
and things like that
they're all special but i tell you the
thing that means the most to me is
is now having we you know we do well and
financially
and then be able to do the things on
behalf of my crew that help out people
right you know like helping people that
aren't as fortunate as us
and i involve my crew when we do that
but i'm the representative i'm like it's
off y'all's hard work
i'd have to say those moments are the
most priceless to me because it's me and
my team doing that and we can help out
some people that need it
is there one that kind of stands out
because or just cheap one you'd like to
cite even
to kind of like well so so here's a good
example so
uh baton rouge has a big buddy program
right and so it was the first thing i
got involved with her office is right
down from the mother ship our first
location
but gay and i she's a wonderful woman
she's devoted her life to help out these
these kids that just don't have the same
opportunities i didn't really
uh do what now gay who you're gay back
she's she's in charge of the big buddy
the director there okay but seeing these
kids go through and helping them when
their kids and
expose some other things and then be
successful later in life they all come
back they'll send letters and giggles
these letters back hey
you influenced me here you did these
things and now hey i got my law degree
or hey i went into entertainment or i
did i went for my dreams and you didn't
give up
so i did i'd have to say that's the best
also just getting from our crew members
man like
the biggest moment recently is you know
last couple years my crew has
breaking me as a top 100 ceo in the
country it's this glass door deal at all
categories there's only a couple of
restaurants in this deal
but that's them voting for that and so
that was the biggest
recognition personally for me is i'm
like my crew just said you know that i'm
a good leader
i got almost 40 000 crew members i can't
see them i don't know them all by name
and things like that but
because of that leadership right that
their leader treats them right and does
that
man you talk about it what an honor
right that's amazing man congratulations
well
it was quite an honor where does it come
from so like uh what was your dad like
when you were young yeah just uh he was
just uh just
always exposed me to business kind of
like i'm doing now and just always about
hard work and then always about
be polite to people things like that
those values and so i do the same things
with my kids now you know i'm like
taking them through it's like
like you met charlie earlier he's a good
young man
you can tell he just has a good uh he's
a bit yeah you can just tell he's a kind
guy right when you meet him
yeah and that's what's the most
important thing in life right i tell
them the most important thing you could
ever do is be kind be kind be kind be
kind to people man and no matter where
and look we they've grown up they've
always had their own money and nice
things and this amazing stuff like he
gets to come here with you and
he meets all the we from kane browns
today with the cane's food truck he gets
to meet all these people oh cool yeah
kane was on a couple of months ago
what a great dude but you know i mean
like but but he gets it like hey
and so what i'm trying to teach these
kids is we're in a great position yeah
and for us we need to help other people
out
amen yeah you know it's interesting i
find um
it's tough cause like i find it tough
whenever i get stressed not
to carry that on to who people that i'm
working with or in my work environment
it's been tough for me sometimes just
personally just to like you know to
it's been tough for me to manage some of
that sometimes yeah i think and i don't
know if it's because i don't take
proper maybe enough care of myself or
like invest
in enough of my self-care kind of to
make sure that i'm comfortable
you know yeah sometimes i have this
thing where i always want to
struggle yeah but that keeps you that
could probably keep you driven right
yeah it keeps me driven but also it
keeps me a little bit stressed out
sometimes i think you know and so
especially now as my as my life has
gotten bigger in the past couple years
it's like
so figuring that out for myself has been
kind of tough you know because
yeah i'd love to be more in that space
where i'm leading through kindness all
the time you know well you know
i wish i could give you some some advice
on that and so the people that are
closest to me working all the time
they see the stressed out todd they see
because man you know how it goes
stacked you're a detail guy like me and
you have to all the details and we need
to be driving
i hate the efficiency of time it's like
we getting to be cranky so the people as
close see
just kind of see that other tie that's
like zip zip zip zip zip and like we're
supposed to be on this in 10 minutes
but they understand and then i'll tell
them look sorry distressed and so they
know this and then i'll take the times
when i can get a breath
i appreciate you i do but i make sure
when i go see my restaurants or i'll go
see the big
offices and do those things i make sure
they just feel nothing but love
right because if they're not around me
enough they don't understand like todd's
just stressed right now i need to be
there
they're busting their butt every day all
the things they're doing so even if i
see something that's not
right where it should be you know and
they do a great job always but i'm not
gonna go in and tell them anything
negative now i'll talk to the district
manager later and
people say hey we probably need to get
this better and i saw this but
motivational but
i'm the same way around your tight group
and they just know you and they love you
and they know you've got all the
pressure on you you know
i think it's hard for that that to leave
but uh i can figure it out someday
yeah or i guess i should just do a
better job sometimes i communicate with
people when i am stressed or say hey
look i'm
i'm not i'm not i'm a little stressed
right now just to let you know if i act
stressed
it's because i am it's not personal yeah
and that's what i do but you always have
to be on for everybody everybody wants
theo you know and the
theo and that's a lot of pressure man
that's a lot that's a lot to have but
yeah them understanding hey i'm tired i
didn't sleep last night
hey i'm going to be stressed right now
just and they know you they know you
they love you and i only got one
chicken finger i'm the chicken finger so
you know
the batter's been all chewed off i feel
like sometimes man that's for sure
um we got a question right here that
came in for you man
what up todd what up theo this is uh
barrett from sulphur louisiana what's up
brother uh first of all
theo i want to say it's real up
that you announced the tour schedule
and there's no dates in louisiana thank
you big time now bouncing back and forth
between la and nashville and you forgot
where you came from
okay show some love man i will give us
some shows alexandria i'm gonna come to
alexandria um
todd i wanna say uh personally thank you
so much
for uh opening up the the cane
store here in sulphur uh right after the
hurricanes
whenever our area was affected by
hurricane laura and here at hurricane
delta
you are one of the first companies if
not the first company that was
uh you know serving food giving people
jobs like giving people stuff to eat man
like
just giving us some semblance of life
being back to normal so
we really appreciate that honestly my
question is
you've already conquered the chicken
tender game so
what's next you know when you got people
like like chick-fil-a
they got all the sauces y'all gonna
start messing with some new sauces
uh you're gonna start doing like bone-in
chicken uh the real question
when are we getting spicy tenders all
right so
let me know what's next in the pipeline
gang gang baby
that's a good question yeah have there
been uh is there anything kind of new on
the horizon or there have been items
answer his question first i'm sorry go
on no it was a great question
um but no i mean i've always believed in
doing one thing and do it better than
anybody else
and uh that's why we have raising cakes
chicken our tack line is one love and i
have one love it says quality chicken
finger meals
and so if you do what you do well and
consistently do it great
your customers will come back and let me
give you a a
reason let me tell you this like it's us
and chick-fil-a are one and two in quick
service average unit volumes like
mcdonald's sales are like a million less
than mine
right it's my repetitive customers that
come back because they're gonna get that
quality every time with a smiling face
and so
if i added different things right added
spicy i've added these
one i wouldn't be as quick in the
drive-through right because the choices
go down
i wouldn't be able to cook it cook to
order like if you come through our line
we have a cook to order system
that literally goes through i have that
whole fry line set up to deliver that
quality meal right with the best quality
you can get
but if i added all these different
things bone-in chicken takes different
times i'd have hold times my quality
would go down my speed would go down
and it wouldn't be our concept our
concept is quality food spurred with
fast food speed and convenience
and adding different things and losing
focus would lose while we're special
so when you even say the choices so
you're even talking to the minutia of
the fact that somebody then at a
drive-through
is having to make choices and that's
going to take more time that's going to
take more time right wow it's
interesting i've never thought of
the time it takes not only on the time
on my side of the counter
as the as the as the company but the
time it takes the uh
like managing the time of the person
showing up without even real
without them even really realizing it
yeah i mean we're over 60 drive through
people want to come through when they
want to get it quick right
people know they're order canes box no
salt extra toast extra sauce boom sweet
tea you're out the door
or you're out through the drive through
and so we want to keep that time to
anneal some even like
not distracting things you know that are
going on like so even we have like right
now i did this russian recovery show but
i got
you know a picture of me and snoop
helping this one restaurant out even
that makes people stop for a little bit
and go do to do maybe ask a question the
window then we're like hey we need to
rethink this right i want them getting
through
because they got 20 cars behind them
yeah you know wow
wow that's interesting man uh was there
now was there ever a moment along the
way where somebody's like hey man
you know you guys need to do uh
always always have always the the
experts are always like hey
you know you guys really need to add a
chicken finger salad
you know the health trends on the da da
da da and the other
and when i was younger i listened a
little more because i'm like wait maybe
these people are smarter than me maybe i
know more than me
and i'm look i'm always constantly
learning but my gut said no
because if i do that chicken finger
salad chicken fish salad the quality is
not
not really there you know it's not the
same thing it won't be craveable
and they want to come back and say that
people told me but they scared me they
were like
well you're gonna get the the cancel
vote like if one person in the car
one of the parents wants it they're not
gonna go to you to go somewhere else i'm
like no
if the kids are gonna push them because
they want that quality right
staying true to what i've done not
listening
i know who i am and i'm not trying to be
all things to all people right because
if you try to be that then you're gonna
you're gonna not not be anything to
anybody right i want that
craveable customer we call them kaniaks
and uh it's paid off brother
yeah and i thought it was cocaine at
first man trust me because i remember
the first time i ever did cocaine was
down at lsu man and i took a run i
thought it was performance-enhancing
drug i didn't know that it was like a
drug for just
night use or whatever so i went on a run
down by blue monitor down by the
railroad tracks dude i probably ran
almost 15 miles
jesus yeah that was not good dude that
was a bad that was a not good for the
heart yeah
good for the heart bro i still sometimes
i can still feel my heart feels like it
has a
horse hoof in it man every now and then
it gets a little trotty
um today's program is brought to you by
the hulu original series modoc
you know i can't stop talking about this
show you know it's the craziest
wildest thing i've seen in a long time
modoc
is a super villain voiced by the
incredible patton oswalt
oh yeah did i mention that modoc stands
for mental organism
designed only for killing
for modoc the only thing harder than
ruling the planet is running a family we
all know that
this show has an amazing cast with
patton oswalt
as modoc along with amy garcia ben
schwartz
melissa fumero wendy mcclendon covey
beck bennett john daly sam richardson
and celebrity cameos as some of your
favorite marvel heroes
marvel's modoc series premiere may 21st
only
on hulu the most joy i have i had in my
career
was before people knew that i was funny
i mean some people knew but before like
a decent amount of people knew
man because then you had the element of
surprise you know
there was something nice about the
element of surprise like
you're going to be surprised you know
you can be surprised when i like this
joke but yeah this thing's right right
yeah and now people probably expect it
right yeah now people expect it which is
great but it it's you can you can't
really replicate that
when you when they didn't know yeah yeah
yeah yeah was there moments like i
noticed in my business as my career goes
on that there are times where it's like
my
career feels like it's on a little bit
of like a
you know on elon musk's golf cart like
it's really cruising you know and then
there's times where it kind of has lulls
and i start to wonder what's going on
take me through some of the trajectory
of how you guys got out of one location
and then what started to happen and if
there were times where you felt like
okay this is where we've kind of
maximized um
did you get into the business like how
do you have to transition from being at
the place to then getting more into the
business side of it
and uh just take me through some of that
please well except for me
you know the whole business has been one
series of getting uh getting your butt
kicked and learning from those mistakes
right so if you're not making mistakes
you're not getting out in the middle of
things right and so
you know one restaurant to the second
was the hardest growth we ever had
you know i grew too quick you know it
was other side of campus the one on lee
drive you probably
went to that one too i probably fried
your chicken late night there and but
but i wasn't i didn't have my staff
ready i didn't have all my people
together and like i thought some people
wouldn't show up on shifts and i'm like
i can't be at both restaurants and then
getting butt kicked there that's
actually when my
my partner ended up saying hey man this
just isn't for me wow so it really
rattled the cage a little well you just
was like look
you're okay coming back all the time and
like when i have time when you have time
off you'll go work on schedules and
doing
learning better training programs he's
like i want to go back read the wall
street journal he was just more of that
business side of it
you know but like going from there then
i grew five restaurants in five months
these old drive-through double
drive-throughs and baton rouge were
going once again i stretched us too much
we did a good job opening up in
lafayette which is the first in
lafayette louisiana the first one out of
the market uh crushed it there but then
i'm like i gotta hit
dallas and houston there's lsu grads
there but i grew in both those markets i
didn't set them up properly i grew too
quick got my butt kicked in both of them
lost a bunch of money until i could
bring it back up
series of things like that and now what
so if there was suggest so how would you
have done it differently looking back on
it a little bit if you could have done
it differently well
just so people can learn yeah yeah so
for me personally it uh
and now with the scale of the business
is it was actually good for me to go and
make those mistakes because
now like i know it sounds like 100
locations down is a lot but look i'm 25
years in the business right we're at
that point i can open quality locations
so i didn't learn the hard way that's
the way i learn you know but if i
if i didn't have to learn the hard way
when i moved to dallas and houston to
put those restaurants in there i would
have slowed down
made sure i had the right team and that
they were properly supported i mean
these people more people didn't have the
right support for me
they worked themselves to the bone that
didn't feel good right you know i
would've gone the right way taking my
time done it right now still
quick you know and got open and did the
things this but i would take a lot more
time setting it up plus the branding in
those areas i thought you just opened
the doors and everybody knew you and
came in
no no it's like a ghost town now i'm
back on the streets trying to get people
in
and so i would have taken my time built
a more strategic plan and then grew from
there but
that helped because when i went to new
markets still today look i'm coming into
nashville now i got the food truck here
it's going around to see people like
seeding the location i'm here personally
people getting to know me things
like that those things have stayed with
me and our openings since those times
have been a lot more successful
you know it's interesting to hear some
of that like jimmy john uh john leotoe
you know he came
he's been on the podcast and he stopped
by this morning to say hey to you which
i thought was really nice
and um he talked about whenever they
first started franchising
how it just got away from him and the
stores weren't how he needed them to be
and he had to go on like a cross-country
tour to all of the locations
and this and and neither buy them back
from the people if they felt like it
wasn't really the right fit
or to keep them you know to inspire them
and kind of
you know give actually put his stamp on
the way it should be done right and to
help them you know and uh i thought that
was pretty fascinating that that seemed
like a moment where he really had to get
back out there and almost do more work
than he had to do in the beginning
absolutely because you know
entrepreneurs you're excitable and you
want to grow and you want to build you
create look
that's our art our art is our business
is growing right and spreading
it we get happy when new people become
braving fans of our brands it's
it's what our gift of the world is and
uh but you get
you get sucked in and you grow too quick
and then you go back and fix it it's way
harder to fix it than to go in the right
way
yeah and so the right way would be what
just a little bit just
be a little more patient you think like
let things take longer than you think
they're going to
yeah look go in with the right team and
so look so my growth
i'm just about all company restaurants
in the united states i got the franchise
what does that mean sorry just so we
know well so like so most of the people
at quick service are franchise models
right right
so you have corporate they have all the
intellectual properties
the names like mcdonald's is a franchise
model franchise model right
subways franchise model taco bell and so
they have the systems and processes then
you go with
local franchisees who basically license
or franchise your concept
and then they go run those restaurants
so they do it you lose a lot of control
when you do that you have to have a real
good franchisees and so
for me i would rather open company
restaurants because i can control them i
mean i want these things run
exceptionally well it's all personal to
me and so i have more control and i
choose to partner with
the restaurant partner i have at that
restaurant who he or she is like
working their butt off they're the todd
graves in their trade area where they
live
and so for me it's a lot more debt you
know people from corporations will
franchise because the local franchisees
will have to put in the debt on the
building and
you know all the startup money and
things like that i'd rather take that
on with my credit facility partner with
my internal people let them become
wealthy and and their family get to
enjoy that and to do it but so
but taking your time is setting it up
getting the right people during your
restaurant whether it's a franchisee or
its company
you need to set those people up for
success you need to train train over
train
you need to have so much support going
in to get them started because it's hard
to get get that
cash flow going it's hard to get that
buzz going in your community so slowing
down
being strategic with growth and i'm glad
you're bringing this up because this
someone might be listening right now
that's
going to grow or something and they're
going to go too quick and it's like
you will have to come back and fix it
and then you'll slow down your growth so
much
set it up with the right people train
properly then give them support
i want to let you guys know that tickets
are now available at theovonne.com
tour we have added shows in st
louis and durham as well as albany new
york
and we are adding another one in
columbus as well they're on sale for
charlotte cincinnati chattanooga
knoxville wilmington
wilkes-barre minneapolis charleston
richmond baltimore
buffalo thank you very much check it out
theovan.com
tour and thank you so much for letting
me live out my dream i'm excited to see
you there
um i'm gonna look good here yeah your
hair looks great by the way oh thank you
very
much man amazing yeah it's coming in
well man i've had hair transplants too
i've had air taken out of the back and
put in the front oh no
your hair's thick man thanks man it's
pretty cool i like getting surgery so
it's like
for me because i like just you wake up
there and there's there's people around
like everybody
cares about you you know i feel like so
cared about when i'm at the surgery
place but
um well i've got the same haircut since
i've been three have you
i guess you know what i could almost see
that man
that's was it did you go to church with
that cutter no yeah they just put a bowl
around my head and cut it now i'm not
that thick anymore so i can't use the
bowl technique
dude my mom used to take me to this lady
miss bobby well first of all
our our our bus driver would cut our
hair in covington so
mr this dude mr nat every like two weeks
he would park the bus on the way home
for a dollar fifty he would cut your
hair dude he literally would just go
around the bus
everybody get the same cut there you go
like literally we all looked like we
were
part of some cult without kool-aid right
like just everybody was just
you show up you just have hair all over
your mom was like what happened the bus
driver i love it i got my hair cut by a
guy named r.l it was a place called
headquarters
and remember back then like the barbers
like they were family like
they got it and we got in high school
see all my friends went to rl
we were like hey can you do this cool
cut this thing i'd be like he'd listen
yeah yeah yeah z
folly had to leave rl you know and we
all did and he took it personally he
hadn't talked to me to this day i am
i believe that man i remember those days
they always had the combs in that little
cup
oh that thing remember that blue liquid
or whatever yeah just sitting in there
it always felt like it was for your dad
you know yeah oh god that was crazy
man
and they would get that other thing with
that kind of like smoke in it or
whatever and put it on your neck
yeah what was that i don't know it's
like that dust yeah it was that powder
it made me all
chalky man i'm like what is this they
thought that was like the nice touch in
the end yeah
yeah it was a little bit old school yeah
it was a little bit i always left out
there looking like benjamin franklin a
little bit i feel like
we got a question that came up right
here for you uh let's get into it
hi todd and theo this is ethan from long
beach california
todd i'm a huge fan of your company
everyone at your stores is always in
such a good mood and is so
friendly i would love to hear more about
this restaurant recovery project you're
doing
it sounds like an awesome cause to
support small businesses
and yeah i really think it's going to be
a great thing for especially during this
time
have a great day thanks brother great
thank you
yeah so when the pandemic started our
business sales actually went up
okay okay so we have drive-thru format
so that became a thing i don't know if
you remember when it when it started of
course you do but
it was like essential business and like
people couldn't go to restaurants but
they could go through drive-throughs oh
wow so drive-through is suddenly just
the luckiest thing on earth
dude exactly and so man like our sales
go up but we're up like 10 even up to 20
percent right it didn't feel good
because where we're getting that
business from was these family-owned
independent restaurants that
predominantly dine in
and so i thought what we could do and i
mean i got on social media and stuff
like support small business
think about going to them they're
suffering us chains are fine you know
and it's like
what can i do i've done tv before i
understand the the power of it and i
said well you know what being an
entrepreneur i said like i went hired a
production company started restaurant
recovery
i knew i could do it during that time my
team was good so i picked 10 markets
where kane's
markets are so i could use our help with
our people pick these
legendary restaurants these family
restaurants are just really going
through a hard time took in a team kind
of like an extreme home makeover deal
got him exposure and involved a lot of
my celeb friends to come help out too
which was really special and neat yeah
rob schneider did one yeah yes i was
nice enough to come out and do uh
the phoenix episode and like just this
family she's a pakistani lady
and does the business with her son omar
and i mean look they
they serve just really really good food
but they're in tempe and the university
shut down no classes about that
going you know overnight and so i
brought rob in uh also deandre hopkins
came in
oh that's cool dude he came in the
monday after the catch these famous cats
in the end zone yeah and so i got him to
come out and these are just community
guys right so
uh rob's like yes i'll help out
deandre's like yes i'll come out so
deandre fired on my team we had to get
this thing done in 48 hours so he
started off they were like wow
work production even went higher than i
could think this group works real hard
and then rob came in with a family like
look they're good to see the stress on
their face but him coming in funny guy
caring they're laughing like look let's
we're gonna get through this together
really great man and
basically the thing i was able to see
more than anything else is they're
all pretty predominantly dining room
business that was gone taken away
so needed to put them into like make
them a to-go machine right
which sounds easy but it's not like to
do it right you got to have mobile
ordering you got to have curbside
delivery takes a lot of technology right
right it's not something a restaurant
owner is just trying to keep the
business open every day
doing racking up credit card debt
keeping their people employed
yeah you could do that right especially
if it's not a man like a you know you
think of a small business guy he shows
up he puts the pot on the stove in the
morning
and starts making the gazpacho or
whatever it is like so yeah that person
isn't going to go from that to having
that app or that ability to uh to make
things mobile they don't have the
resources for that right so i could go
in and help them do that and then
preserve these places right i mean
look you know i'm a chain and
i like getting business obviously right
we do a good job and we work hard for it
but
we have all the advantages i got a huge
marketing budget right
got big shiny buildings right in the
best locations and people see that and
it's that constant state of mind so what
i try to tell people
is hey i'm glad you came to keynes but
look think about that
neighborhood restaurant that you love
like they need your business they don't
make that much money
and when they're gone they get replaced
by high-rise
or a chain we don't need more of those
we need those legendary restaurants
diversity of thoughts small business go
to that small hardware store
you got to go the big box to get some
stuff go to that little hardware shop go
go support that small business a
background backbone of our country
plus different thoughts it makes things
great they're the cultural centers of
our neighborhood we need to support them
yeah do you worry about i know like
minimum wage increase and stuff like
that do you worry about that affecting
businesses like i hear
stuff about like that do you worry about
that affecting small businesses yeah i
worry about
the people that just don't have enough
sales to support it and might not have
as sophisticated pricing strategies okay
so
for me you know quick service
restaurants
might make between five and ten percent
bottom line okay so
everybody that comes in you're doing
good if you made five cents on a dollar
ten 10 cents on a dollar you're doing
great and so that means if somebody
spends a dollar you make 10 cents
you make doing well it's usually five
between five cents and ten cents so
there's just not much margin there right
wow and between that five and ten cents
for every dollar spent there when you
have commodity pressures and things like
that which price a chicken goes up then
it just goes down and so you just got
slim margins that's four
before taxes that's five cents to ten
cents a dollar before then you go get
the taxes so if i spend ten dollars at a
raising cain's
right at a what's the quick service you
talking about yeah quick service fast
food
okay so if i spend ten dollars at a
quick service restaurant
then if they're making 10 cents of that
so if they're making a dollar out of 10
dollars that i spend then they're doing
well
doing well wow that's 10 percent doing
well then that's before taxes right and
that's real numbers huh that's real
numbers and so when you think about it
we don't have margin to share right
because
um if labor prices go up
right and you got to do it you have to
pass it on to the customer there's no
way
that you can supply because if it goes
below five percent and gets lower you
can't lose money well and then you can't
go
you're not gonna go put the uh
investment in to build and grow and
create more jobs and do it right so
the next location the roi is not there
and so you won you wouldn't spend the
money and two the banks are gonna be
like hey you're not making return on
investment like we're not gonna continue
to lend you money
and so just the margins are that small
but so for me it doesn't
it doesn't hurt keynes because you're
gonna eventually pass it on right
wages go up then you're going to raise
the price of the chicken finger box
right it's just going to go up
and we have and you can't do that
overnight you have to stage into it and
so we're
we just have a lot of resources man i
mean like i have a strategy for pricing
the tough artists for small business
that don't think about that pricing and
then they don't want to do it the next
thing you know their their margins go
too small but
look it's going there fifteen dollars uh
uh an hour minimum wage
we're going there i just i give advice
to small business i'm like
you have to pass it on and we're going
to go up but plan your pricing
strategies
ease into it and let your customers know
hey look just it's it's
labor prices and so it goes up so it
doesn't really concern me
it's a pricing strategy for small
business right because you have such a
bra
such a breadth of of information you can
pull in and you can look at it and you
can like
plan on a big scale but for someone
who's just kind of like made their menu
and it's very basic and
they're not thinking like oh well if the
cost of this goes up 50 cents
then i don't even make any money until
probably six months down the line when
they look at their books and like what
happened
what happened that's exactly what
happens and they don't these all these
small business owners they are so
reluctant to take price increases they
don't want their customers to pay i'm
like
i know you have to or you're going to be
out of business you know isn't that
interesting about that about that about
sometimes about
people don't want to charge like i get
that way sometimes like i don't want to
make my tickets real expensive you know
i don't want to
even though sometimes i'll see other
people like holy smokes you know that
guy's tickets that price that's crazy
you know
but i'll get nervous about that i i
don't even know if it's nervous i don't
want to bother i don't want to
i don't know what it is i know i i think
i only take a crack at it
you start it from nothing and you
appreciate every fan and it means
something to you so it's you take it
personal right and so
you generally hold back same with small
business right they started from nothing
they've scratched they called and now
they have a a living and they don't want
to pass that on they're like i don't
want to do that to my customers i would
imagine you're probably the same way
yeah and it's exact opposite in big
corporate america especially in
restaurants
like those cfo types are like they
already have their pricing
it's not a personal decision it's all a
financial decision that they're doing
it's different for people that that care
you know
is it interesting at a certain point as
you grow and as
things turn more from like sit like
manning a fryer
to um
to like business like i noticed with
business the more business
i start doing the more business i have
to do you know and so it's tough because
you want to grow and you want to make
things bigger
and give other people opportunities but
it also like it's it's tough to be like
how much is enough business you know how
much is enough
revenue like how much is enough you know
have there been moments in your world
where you've kind of battled with that
kind of stuff
or yeah absolutely you know all on the
way and so
what i had to set for myself was my
personal goals
and what ultimately i see happiness
being for me okay and so i set the
vision for raising canes and this is our
vision statement
is to have locations all over the world
be known as the brand for quality
chicken finger meals
okay great crew cool culture and active
community involvement
okay so that's me happiness right and so
look
i believe god made me good at this for a
reason and that's to be able to help
people right
but when i set that vision you think
about it it's not just i won't have
locations all the world there's nothing
about i want to make a bunch of money
i've got all these things in there
it's literally while i went to keynes
great food
then oh wow friendly crew cool culture
and then they give money back and they
work in the communities so that's guided
me right and so when i know i
i know i need to do that then i'm going
to grow it and so mine's an infinite
vision like i
i won't see it all over the world you
know i mean i'm gonna we're starting to
grow but i can't develop the whole world
you know i mean by the time i'm you know
god willing to live a long life but
you know those things are going so
that's helped to guide me right
and so i passed up my financial goals
really early on
and so for me is when time hits the
grind hits and it always hits
it kept me motivated when i didn't have
the team around me that helped support
me always had people that worked hard
and did but i couldn't afford
the teams i do now right i knew i'd get
to this point
and look by the grace of god right now i
got really really solid teams very
much more smarter than i am and in the
respective things they do
so we're a stronger team and i feel like
now just now and i'm pushing 50 i'm 49
now
almost 25 years in business just now
that i'm not like waking up every
morning with that thing in my belly but
i'm
i'm hitting that vision so wow anyway
but different times it hit i'm like oh
my god todd you know
you're so stressed out you know you
haven't you haven't
relaxed or you haven't done time family
and things like that
and then i was like but look that vision
puts me through ultimately it's going to
really help people
and and you just got to stick with it
and go you know and so that was just my
personal thing and so
that's paid off by setting real goals
like people need to set real goals and
real vision
considering what you're working for some
people get beyond that and look they
don't want to grow like me all over the
world they want to do certain things and
in
all walks of life and then they get lost
in wait a minute this is what i really
wanted to do and it wasn't what i wanted
to do to be happy right so now they're
bigger
they're this but they're not happy right
and that that's kind of a heartbreaker
you know at times you know something
people need to think strategically
where am i going you know yeah it's
interesting man yeah i think about that
sometimes like i think one of our
original goals with podcasting was just
to kind of share what we're thinking and
feeling
and then to we started getting into like
helping and like giving back
we do some stuff for single moms and
things like that where we try to
we haven't gotten it like incorporated
yet so we could make it like a real
non-profit you know that that arm of it
but i certainly hope to at some point um
but sometimes i have to remember that
that's what's kind of important you know
yeah
that's leaving something positive you
know it almost feels so stale to make
money if
there's not some positive part of it in
a way there's got to be
something greater than us to go do it
right and look man
i'm at a point now where i can do a lot
of things and with the scale of the
business and do it
giving you get so much more back right
and then it just gives your life purpose
right so
giving comes in other ways not just
charity just giving money to these
things is it's inspiring people you know
it's it's it's someone saying hey
i have this dream and like look this
chicken finger guy did it
even commercial fish in alaska
reconstructed the first place but he's
working hard
and i can do it you know what i mean
those things are gifts that you can give
people look how much we learn from
people on the way
you know what i mean people say hey
you're self-made man i'm like
no i'm not man i'm a collection of what
i wanted to do but help but people along
the way right you know
so giving back parts really cool what
were some um
was it was there an item so i don't
forget was there a uh
was there a menu item you guys ever
tried like a banana pudding was there
something you guys ever
came out with or tried or that was the
closest one even early on
man no i just stick stuck with that one
love brother
same menu since day one man and just
knowing that but that's been a big key
to my successes
is just like i said knowing that's what
i do stay focused
man i've never even added dessert and
i'm not anti-dessert not anti-dessert
it just would take focus off of what
we're doing you know and so look so
here's the interesting thing in san
antonio airport we went in there
they have city mandates and so you had
to have a healthy item you had to add
uh breakfast and then they even wanted
dessert when it well-rounded
so we added a chicken finger salad for
them right it started off 20 of sales of
chicken finger salad
and then it slowly dipped it back then
it went rapid and became one percent of
sales because people are like once they
try the chicken fingers it just shows
you like right
it's it's a non-item for me right we
have these great cookies all this stuff
is people need to deserve canes you
finish that man you're good to go
so then but but for those locations you
had to have that
city mandates right they just need yeah
they just the city council says hey we
need healthy we need
we need these things to make it
well-rounded because like sometimes it
scares them a concept like mine
going in because it's just that one
thing right we don't have that problem
anymore now
what uh dessert did y'all put in that
airport it's cookies they have these
great
chocolate cookies you know and i could
get the pucks and i mean i tried
thousands of cookies and all that but
like in the end you know people got in
the beginning but that meal so flavorful
and good
that cookie couldn't match that chicken
i was i'm not a cookie guy i can't make
that same kind of dessert so
look everything on my menu has to be
exceptional right
freshly brewed tea look i sourced my tea
from three different countries and like
i know the tea leaves are coming in
freshly squeezed lemonade i can do it on
crushed ice so it's like
laser focus on these items being good
and then keeping that what's hard is
when you scale
like i have so many different
procurements across the country to get
these products i'm constantly trying our
food we have actually a big r d culinary
team
just to make sure it stays consistent
right wow
man i uh was there
at certain points did you have to get
help like one thing i struggle with
sometimes is
asking for help you know or sourcing out
work you know that sort of thing like
knowing that it's not going to be done
how i want it to be done that sort of
thing you know some control issues
probably just
things that i use as a child that would
help me control my world you know
but that as now as an adult aren't
really as helpful not to just like trust
my employees that i
that i trust you know i don't have a
bunch of employees but just like i
noticed that even in all in all walks of
my life even in relationships like
to trust somebody to care about me all
that kind of stuff did you notice in in
your
in your business were there moments
where it was like
okay i'm not doing like was it tough to
go into that space because obviously you
can't do all this alone what was some of
that experience like was it hard for you
as a person to do something oh man it
was so hard right so
i was a person frying everybody's
chicken you know every piece of
equipment like the first location you
used to go to man like i put in every
board i mean i like
literally that's my baby so i was used
to doing all of it was it by serranos
were you restaurants oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah right there on that right there
varsity the serranos and canes right oh
yeah my ex-girlfriend used to forget
serrano
good margarita yeah they had i mean they
had everything in there dude everything
was good good margarita it's uh it's
something else now unfortunately it's
gone but chimes are still there
yeah and they added a rooftop at times
you see that cool oh man i live a minute
from there man i'll
go out there and have beers all the time
man okay this time of year was nice
and this is lsu this is lsu campus for
listeners that don't know this is all
right
off of the uh north gates of lsu campus
and it's nice being part of that
community because you have all the old
ones louie's you know the breakfast spot
you know
yeah my mother went there a couple weeks
ago actually there you go and like
frenchie's always in there cooking your
food and clark has highland coffees and
you have
you have chimes you have the varsity you
have raisin cane's original mothership
and that
whole community is just great i actually
have the raisin canes i have
i got i've lived in the apartment behind
the first gains and so literally that's
where i started construction
did everything there that's why my dog
was out there kane and a friend said you
ought to name it raising canes after
your dog like oh nice
all happened because it was right there
it's nice being part of the community
yeah you guys built that
dog park too over there yeah yeah yeah i
love that yeah dude i took my nephew
there so i didn't know where to take him
we didn't even have a dog so i took him
over there my brother let me watch him
for a couple hours dude i took him over
there he was literally
tackling basset hounds out there it was
unbelievable man
and then something nipped at him i think
a little shiba inu or something nipped
at him and so we had to take him home
but
yeah man that kid could catch a ball in
his mouth dude no doubt man
my nephew's a wildcat yeah i took him
right there that's cool i love it you
didn't have a dog
you're like i'll bring you there
there'll be dogs you can oh i took him
there too yeah he was really dangerous
man but
he did an upgrade there but uh at the
dog park maybe with new sections it got
used
so much he couldn't even keep grass and
stuff so uh it's nice over there thank
you guys for doing that
um but just look back to your deal on
the on the being able to like yeah the
controller
control deal and i'm extremely detailed
and this is my baby
and so over time it really hindered me
it really did it hurt our growth it hurt
our
creative thinking because i was just
overly overly controlling
and then i learned it's kind of a
maturity thing right over time
then you say hey you look at a series of
getting screwed up and getting beat up
and getting tired and all those things
along the way you're like look i need to
bring in people
and the biggest strength as you build
your teams is bringing people are
smarter than you you know wow
not a threat bring in people that are
good at their own respective ways
and then you do it but it doesn't mean
not being a detailed oriented it doesn't
mean you're not into the details
and you're not helping people like oh
just delegate like just delegate what
kind of word is that no it's it's
work with great leaders but still be in
the details but it helps to scale you so
i had to learn that way and i tell you
it's the best of my workload thinking
about right now 600 locations we'll do
100 next year
but my workload's better than it ever
has been and my balance of life because
i've trusted my teams
i'm into the details right i'm still
doing that
but i've trusted people to come in that
are better than me and grow so that was
a big big maturity
learning for me man it's hard it's hard
is it hard
and then you screw up again and then you
run people off because they're like i
don't hear about
the things and so i finally and like i
said now i'm pushing 50 i've really kind
of matured into that
doing but it's interesting interesting
too it's like it's really important
it's not details you should be in the
details so
people used to tell me the experts again
like you just won't know what these
things are going on you can't do these
things when you get big
right well i'm bigger than all of them
now right and so but like i do know this
like
my co-ceo aj kumaron they said you can't
keep writing notes to people
he wrote a thousand notes the other day
right he's like i'm going to take my
time
and do the things because i'm going to
scale you know um
edison sweat sweats is the boating
company off of louisiana
well anyway he built barry swift he
built these boats
you know crew boats all this stuff to
support huge company multi-billion
dollar company
he even got down to the details in his
business to know how much the bottled
waters they were spending because
there was just this rampant spending on
bottled waters no one was looking at he
said look
it's not just a bottle of water our
company makes billions of dollars but
that carries over to everything else him
staying in the details like most
successful
people i know stay in the details but
they trust people hmm
interesting balance it's hard it's hard
man it is hard and then you get your
butt kicked so many times and finally
you kind of
settle into it and see the see the
strength of it almost out of exhaustion
huh yeah
were you surprised whenever you started
to trust people how things flourish were
you almost shocked
absolutely and it was also trial and
error me getting used to it and also
trusted some people that weren't
as great as they should have been and we
fall back but look it's just
more mistakes and you learn from them
i've gotten really good
at understanding talented people but at
kane's if you're going to work at keynes
you can be the smartest person in the
world and good at what you do if you
don't have heart or line with the values
of our company
or this vision you don't work out and
it's really interesting so
what i used to do to do serious
interviews which i thought was
is about five times as long now i mean
like for people's positions like we
spend so much more time because
i don't want them to come in and not be
successful this is these people's lives
and as important as mine
but taking that extra time then it's
there's people you can trust better
right you get through that process
what type of person does it take to run
a uh
run a store to be a partner in that
business what type of
you know you must know by now what type
of person it takes yeah
first off it takes someone who loves the
food business right it's it's
interesting business it's a hard
business you got to love it so look
on my sleeve at raising canes it says
fry cook cashier my business card says
founder chairman ceo fraca cashier it's
like
you got to be a fraud code cashier you
got to love it i like working fry lines
i like working drive through i love the
pace of the business i like cooking
you know all these things and so you
have to get someone that just
loves that business you have to get
somebody that's positive
like like we talked about a positive
motivational management people that want
to encourage people through
because you get so much more with the
honey then you try more flies with honey
than uh
then whatever else vinegar i think
scotch or scotch yeah
yeah so anyway so it's like you got to
have someone that's aligned to those
values
and somebody that knows the purpose is
bigger than them right it's about
helping people because
when you're someone does you know five
people get sick or can come in and
you've got to cover those shifts and do
these things
also there's sacrifice you know i mean
like we value family like you see me
with my kids and so do this stuff but
sometimes
something's going wrong you have to miss
that t-ball game now we want you to make
the next one
you know what i mean but it's that
commitment to say and to be a community
leader
you know that those are the things that
resonate and man we get people that are
really great from other concepts they
come into keynes and it's like this is
my last stop and i'm here forever and
then we can partner and then
they become like the todd graves in
their community wow so pretty cool
that's interesting man
and uh and sometimes you need help and a
person or
group or
place that is not even a place actually
that can help you is better help
you can start communicating with a
therapist soon quickly under 48 hours
the services available for clients
worldwide if you're in india
bagistan
new delhi north dakota get help better
help
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free
to change counselors if needed you know
i was having a tough day i was driving
to see my friend i pulled over on the
side of the road
next thing you know i'm better help
facetiming with this dimey little blonde
uh
therapist honestly so better help want
you to start living a happier life today
visit their website yep visit
betterhelp.com
theo that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help
of an experienced professional this
podcast is sponsored by better help
and this past weekend listeners get 10
percent off their first month
at betterhelp.com theo sean we got a
good question that came out was that one
you pulled up or
yeah there we go that's it yep yo yo
it's gio palermo from akron ohio what's
up mr raisin kane
um i had a question for you today
i'm a big fan of your establishment your
chicken establishment your buns
your coast law all the the chicken the
fries
big fan of that but i was wondering you
know you're in a very competitive market
against a lot of good chicken um
chicken establishments and i was
wondering who do you fear the most in
the chicken game yeah do you
fear you know the zaxby's chicken the
bojangs
the chicky filet the popeyes the
churches
you know um let me know who's your who
are you scared of who you fear the most
yeah gang gang who's that foul voldemort
man who's the dark yeah who's that
who's the colder part of voldemort so
fortunately
we are very symbiotic with all those
concepts right
so we're next to every chick-fil-a you
know i mean in this in the trade areas
we're doing business in we're next to
chick-fil-a we're next to popeyes we're
next to zaxby's we're next to all those
and what we see
is since we've stayed true to our one
love our chicken finger meal
someone will go to chick-fil-a on a
tuesday but then on thursday they're
coming to get our chicken finger meals
right
they know what we're about they might go
to zaxby's as a really expanded menu so
which is works for them is good so then
someone might get a salad from there
they might
go somewhere else and get bone chicken
you know at popeyes but
we don't see like our competitors can
run some kind of like special like
we get a bunch of competitors but they
might run a special on chicken fingers
like we don't lose a
cent of business they know they're
coming for our quality our sauce
our things so we do well with all the
national players
um we actually should we do better than
most of them
the thing that gets me is the young
person that has the fire of todd graves
going that wants to come and
compete directly right and you know says
hey i'm gonna go head-to-head with canes
i'm gonna do the same thing they do
and do it and we get it all the time now
what it does is once again that
entrepreneur instance is so personal to
me and my team you better get up early
in the morning you better work late at
night man because this is what we do
this is my it's part of my dna man it's
representation of my family so you bet
you better come with all your guns
because i love young entrepreneurs and
everybody takes ideas from everybody
right i mean guthrie started the whole
phenomenon
but like you better bring it you're
going to pete compete with raising canes
because this is my world
dang that's it now have you ever thought
about do you guys go to like china is
there like an asian like has ever been
like a
like a rice in canes or like sometimes i
remember one time i remember being in um
i think i was in singapore and the kfc
the colonel on the sign there
is an asian colonel like i never thought
about that before i'd always just
thought it looked like the same kind of
like basic caucasian guy
right so has there been um do you guys
are you guys a global brand right now
no we're in the middle east so i went to
the middle east first for a couple
reasons one partner
muhammad al-shaya we resonate with each
other on values right so he's like
one of the large players there does all
kind of franchisees puts
puts the right people behind it he cares
and we're lying value-wise right so he's
like some of his values are like
getting the middle eastern people in the
workforce right because oil's gonna
dry up one day right you know what i
mean like working women you know
like these countries man like we had one
of the first women drivers come through
our drive-through and saudi in the
kingdom man that felt good that's right
wow
seeing what things change over time
right like getting to play music
and saudi like they're all no music you
can't do these things it's like let's
play some instrumental saudi music like
i gotta have music when you're going
somewhere
now the crazy ones don't play some wild
music instrumental music
now you can play this classic music in
your restaurants
things like that so he and i were
committed and we knew and if there was a
problem we could work through it
together so one was partner then two the
middle east they
accept american concepts like don't have
to change it don't have to do other
things because
like i haven't changed the menu my whole
adult life right right
so i want to go somewhere and prove that
it's working well it's doing well we got
like 30 in the whole area
um they're crazy about it um we don't
have the international celebrity
like everybody knows us so we build the
business and so
i'm really excited next step asia and
like i said i don't really want to
change
what i do i might consider something
with the slogs i'm not i'm not a
sloth fan like people always like do you
like your slaw i'm like no man don't
like the slaw
that's why you can trade it out for
extra toast or or sauce
um but maybe we'll play with some things
like their local produce they like slaw
too but
maybe something like that but like i'm
not changing what i do you know what i
mean and if i had to change what i do to
go in somewhere then
i just don't need to go there right do
y'all cook the toast extra if people ask
for it
do we do it now we all cook the toast
extra if people ask for it like
like longer yeah yeah we'll give the
customer what they want now it drives me
crazy because it's like it uh look we
have underground menus and they get
different stuff and it's like it slows
down the line but i'm not going to tell
the customer no yeah i want to give them
what they want
yeah i like a little bit extra even if i
get pancakes i ask them to cook them
extra crispy yeah that's like a little
more crisped out a little bit for some
reason
um sean to be another question that came
in what up
theo it's nate from iowa
just thought i'd call into the show see
if this works you know
ask a question for mr graves uh
first of all theo i love your show it's
such a huge encouragement to me man
and thanks brother mr graves i just want
to ask you
um when you're cooking it up in the
kitchen
you know at home are there any songs
that you like to listen to or artists
you like to listen to me personally i
like to listen to a little frank sinatra
you know what i'm saying
you ever think about getting in the
spaghetti business because i'm making
some meatballs tonight baby
oh gang oh wow he's got some beautiful
balls sand
anyway thank you mr graves thank you
theo
gang gang bro thank you for the question
man yeah
do you like a little bit of background
what do you enjoy todd
music wise yeah everything man
everything i'm a big fan of music love
music and that's why in restaurants when
i started my restaurants man we're
listening to them using kitchen it's
crazy people used to not do that
and i'm like we're listening to music i
like it all man so i like it i like my
country
i like my national country i like my old
school red dirt country
from uh from texas i love my boys
playing black
well uh clint black really wouldn't
guess just to say more of a robert roll
king
oh you know and all these young guys
coming cowetzel and
those guys man they just got they got a
good sound and they're pure who they are
i'm out of the old graves
oh that guy's great willie nelson's so
good oh he's great and he likes canes
and he's such a nice guy
my chicken finger adventures i got to
meet all these really cool people billy
gibbons last night i got to meet i mean
how cool but um and they're all canes
fans which is crazy
we'll get into that later but uh i like
that down to like a dean martin i play
when i cook it depends on the mood i
like travis scott i mean like
post malone i just like all forms of
music and for me is staying relevant
right i got a young fan base right
a young young fan base and so not
becoming a dinosaur
and just listening to your old stuff so
it's good having kids and go through
this
but it's fun because i'm friends with
these artists so like grabber scott gave
me these shoes right oh god
he grew up in missouri city and he went
to the canes and they were crazy about
it
and then he grows and he hears a story
this guy started this and then they want
to meet post he's like i got to become
friends and
and these are brilliant guys but they're
cool as hell right and it's like
so listening their music means means
more to me right
right it's like you're staying in touch
with something yeah you stay in touch
with something and you know they're out
there
working hard you know they got good
hearts you know and snoop dogg's a great
friend and so he was in baton rouge
years ago he's driving through the
original canes right he was down there
with master p
oh yeah oh man that was like town when
he came in it was great bro that was a
crazy time so i remember i would used to
go to the rec center right
yeah and master p this is when this is
before c murder had gone to jail
and silk the shocker they would they
would be in there and they used to fly
like
nba players would fly in and play at the
lsu rec center i know i used to go man
watch these guys ball they could play
dude it was crazy yeah and they would
have i remember they had these guys who
would stand on the side of the court
holding like their clothes they were
gonna wear after literally the guy's job
was to stand there with his arms
straight out it was almost like they
were clothing racks
and they would have all their clothes
draped over them that they were going to
wear after the after they played
and we'd go sit in there and watch them
uh yeah just playing the wrecks
it was a crazy time wasn't it man it was
great and so so dog snoop dogg would
drive through
canes afterwards and they'd always have
that extra box and he's like
who's the box for for p you know because
b always went back
i guess he was the one changing doing he
had a great business going then but
it's nice to resonate with these guys
and so like with snoop and he helped me
out with the
uh wrestle recovery episode in l.a
because he's got a big heart but like
when we get together we go to this
compound we talk about kids we talk
about what we're doing charity we're
talking about friends like
people know as an entertainer all these
guys look like good heart good soul and
so
this is what gives me hope for the
future is these younger ones too they
got heart they're good people just like
you you've got good values
and these younger people look up to you
all right they look up to you but when
you keep showing these good values
then people go okay the people i think
are coolest in this world are the ones
that are
working hard and they have good values
right i don't know many successful
people
that don't that aren't good people you
know jaylen ramsey's here in town
he's a superstar in his deal but i'm
meeting with his dad later tonight he
and his dad were having dinner things
like that
one of the best backs and then on the
other end michael thomas one of the best
receivers of all times right
we talk about family stuff good stuff we
have a good time too now you know what i
mean but
it's all about that stuff and so it
makes me feel good about our country
because when
you have i like supporting celebrities
and they're kind of charity because
it gets amplified and that means where
people say if these superstars have this
humility and they got these values
then i want to be i want to be like them
right role models just like you you will
not believe your influence
that goes through to other people and
the things you're doing just like our
man nate just said
he really appreciates you and an
inspiration to him and i think
all of us whether you're chicken finger
famous or here are
our in your world we need to be good
examples
these things that matter man some of
these things that don't matter they
don't matter in those people's lives we
need
we need inspiration yeah it's uh
especially these days it's tough because
a lot of mainstream media seems like it
battles against that they don't
you know it's not like and that could
just be not even true i mean but
it seems like there's a lot of dark arts
that are more out there at play
yeah so it almost seems like a time
better to kind of lean into the good and
uh and just try our best more than ever
right now leaning to the good
leading to the positive support each
other be cool to each other you're like
me you've got friends from all walks of
life right
we're doing these things let's don't let
people think that we don't care we got a
long way to go
yeah as a society but like pitting
people against each other
and making sensationalism out of it
making money off people being against
each other
wrong move for our country wrong move
it's going to get
so bad that then they'll have to cycle
back because people are stuck
they're not listening as much to the to
the negative and the sensationalism
they're starting to figure it out
yeah yeah i think that's pretty cool to
see um when so when you look to your
horizon of life like uh
was there a moment where you realized
okay i can
not take a break but i've achieved
i've achieved you know i think there's a
thing inside of entrepreneurs like
some girl asked me the other day she
goes how is your life like now you know
you kind of have some of the things that
you want or you've achieved some of your
successes some of your goals
and i was like man it's not really that
different the gas pedal that's always
kind of had me be like i want to do
stuff
has never really the foot never really
comes off it
i don't think it's always kind of this
now what kind of thing like not always
in a bigger way but now
what maybe in a more important way or
now what
um in more of a human way you know it
might have it has evolved some
but um was it remember where you kind of
realized okay
ah you know a little bit yeah yeah so uh
financially right so we we hit on this
earlier but like
growing it meeting my wife then going
through now i got kids
i'm highly leveraged i wanted to go and
have
things now i'm not talking rolls royces
and stuff but like
education decent house you know things
like this and so
that was a big one because i was
levering the business too much and
the big lesson to me is i had 28
locations when hurricane katrina hit all
south louisiana
okay mostly south louisiana 21 of 28 of
those went down
i levered the business what i was doing
is banking back then was
was was a lot more lenient and what i
would do is
i'd go into community find a community
bank then i'd have a sub debt investor
meaning
subordinated debt to the bank i could go
raise
100 200 000 and give them a subordinated
note to the bank means the bank gets
their money first
and but i'ma pay you a 15 return this is
just kind of my
entrepreneurial financing what i did and
the banks would actually kind of use
that as equity
saying what you got 200 000 it's like an
equity thing terrible thing you're just
totally leveraging yourself
yeah it's a lot is a lot but i was able
to do all these locations and dignity
ding and i don't want to sell i didn't
want private equity partners i wanted i
wanted to own it and control it
and when it went down so like our
restaurants had opened a restaurant
so first paycheck to crew members is two
weeks
i got sales coming in pay the vendors 30
days
right pay rent in 30 days so i was
creating cash right like i didn't have
to do my expenses
sales are coming in so when i kept
opening these locations i kept creating
cash for the company and kept growing
highly levered it
totally stupid by the way because often
katrina comes in
you got cash flow stops and you're like
whoa like i almost just screwed up the
whole thing man i mean
and i would have bounced back and came
back but it wouldn't be what we are
today
wow but we were able to rally our troops
we were the first ones to open
our business survived and did well but
i'll never forget that deal
and then it stayed with me that ache in
my belly like because i'm putting
everything towards canes i'm
everything's leveraged i'm in monstrous
debt and i just didn't have that nest
egg for my family you know what has
something happened to me you know what i
mean what happens out to mom or whatever
especially when your last name is graves
you're freaking halfway there you're
already halfway there right reaper's
already freaking you know he's already
got a tattoo on you yeah
so it that felt good when i was able to
put money aside and do that
and put it away but you know and and so
that was like a
but with that vision and what i want to
do like to me is i
keep working hard for that vision
because i know it's my purpose right
right and i believe with people like us
okay like
when you create and do you're never
going to stop creating and doing because
it's part of what you are it's part of
your dna and i do i do firmly believe
this
if you're not going ahead it doesn't
need to be this but if you're not moving
forward on things if you're not
creating if you're not working you're
not doing things then you're sliding
behind there's no
coast like in all my life's experiences
you always got to kind of do if we're
this way whether it's this or this we
have to keep going like
if you stop you slip back yeah and look
at people which i think is retirement
you know if some people want to retire i
think that's when they're
hey i'm gonna go fishing more i'm gonna
do all those things but if you're
staying in the game
you're always gonna go never being
satisfied
and that's a terrible saying right but
like always wanting more is better way
and that's how you said it is
is a good thing because you want to push
yourself if you're satisfied and you say
hey this is perfect this is saying we've
we've achieved it
you know like that's the second you
think you made it is a time to be
showing the door
right you know you got to push and do
because you don't want to go back
and you want to keep creating and doing
good things and it keeps you sharp and
it keeps you going
but it's important to celebrate your
successes and what we won't do is we'll
do all these great things with our
business
but we won't stop and say hey let's
celebrate i mean it's for an hour i feel
like nick saban after after damn
alabama wins again he's like we're
starting recruiting in the morning but
he's a champ and i look like i respect
the heck out of you know but i'm like we
have to celebrate so celebrating success
is i think is important
even it's just one night you know you're
right man somebody told me that the
other day said man sometimes you gotta
look you you
always want to do more for other people
and want to make people feel good
and you don't even look and realize
you're doing that
you know you're doing it and then like
and you have to then it makes she gives
you win your sales right if you can
realize that
then you'll go do more yeah you know i
thought it was really interesting how
you said where your vision meets your
vision and purpose and how they kind of
can interchange and how
i think it'd be really interesting to
just kind of have that in people's minds
and hearts like
as almost like a a chart or something
where it's like yeah well your vision
and your purpose
because those are two different things
but they're very this they're similar
but they're
one is almost more of a divine and one
is almost more of a will
yeah and i think it's interesting um
that's well well said if you can tangle
those up almost braid them in a way
yeah i breed them just by i know what my
purpose is
and the vision with the business is
going to get us there right
then setting setting goals right so
where keynes is going to be
25 in august and they're like how you
want to celebrate i want to do 25
million dollars the communities we do
business in
you turn 50 in february i want to do 50
million dollars back in the business
but setting those personal goals too
then then you get a plan behind it what
can we do with these things right
so that's that vision strategy the will
other side
the purpose is more divine why are you
here what is your purpose
yeah and ask ourselves that and answer
it honestly to ourselves too you know
yeah i think sometimes it can be scary
even to hear what the answer is you know
it can seem like hard work um but i
think yeah once
it's scary too because you have to when
you lock into something
and you do it you becomes your life work
you know what i mean like i better make
a good decision this is what
it is my purpose because look there's no
backing out of that you know when i make
promises to people
uh what's your daily routine like todd
and then we'll get you on your way here
oh man it's it's kind of everywhere like
like a is it
sporadic or do you have like are you
like this you know it's a little both so
um we have so being in the details of my
business are so many different
committees we have set up right so i got
i approve every uh location i was
looking at some in nashville earlier
earlier today
um every design of every restaurant
every local cultural graphic that goes
into the restaurants now i have
incredible people in teams
they pull it all together i get to
review maybe make a couple of points on
things
but then it goes to hr issues called
crew resources i created a
a division called kane's love it's about
appreciating recognizing respecting
rewarding crew members
on and on purchasing supply chain
culinary trying the chicken
i mean you name it it's every part of
the business financials reviews all that
stuff
so we have regular committee meetings
set up because a lot of people come in
and do it i can work my schedule around
that
then it's getting out to the market
seeing my people seeing you personally
do those things
you know are is important they're out
pandemic i mean i didn't stop i went to
our markets i went and saw our people
they're in our restaurants working so i
need to get out and about a lot of
things too is going to see
um some of these famous kaniaks too
seeing them
appreciate them right so they like to
spend time but then they also they'll go
back and post
you know and like i appreciate that
right they post eden canes things like
that so someone said look i appreciate
that you know 100 million people saw
that or whatever crazy stuff like that
so it's kind of that whole crazy mix you
know i mean catch my son's baseball
games
uh do fun stuff with my daughter and
stuff like that and just kind of
keep it going i think you know
entrepreneurs have a high energy level
so you're able to do a lot of capacity
uh but that's just kind of how uh how i
roll every week i gotta get my mom asked
me where you going next week i'm like
i don't even think about it yeah yeah
it's yeah it's almost too much sometimes
when you rattle up when you really stack
the future onto today you know it can
get to be a lot
sean any other question that you wanted
to get answered in other videos
okay cool man uh tigers thank you so
much man for coming in today oh one last
question i had
so jimmy john before whenever he was in
he talked about sometimes how
time went on with work that one of the
things that ended up leading to him
not wanting to sell but one of the
things that wasn't as much joy was that
a lot of there became like a lot of
lawsuits and legal issues the bigger his
company got
is that um do you notice that you have
to spend more time like
the bigger you get the the the more time
you have to spend almost doing
yeah stuff like that not fun stuff yeah
they're not fun stuff
yeah yeah i mean look works work and
sometimes it's the grind but when you
have
these litigious lawsuits that come
that's not real look like we screw up
always back us but like
setups and these things come in that are
not true
yeah got it spent the time snakes and
you gotta spend your time
and your money and you have to go back
and defend this stuff and you're really
defending your
honor your values and your things and
it's like i have a crew that go we're
not this way we're not this
all the time the bigger you get the
bigger target you are
the system is set up to go in and do
that and to settle
so it just comes constantly man that's
the stuff that just like it just takes
it out of you and you know what but but
being aj my co-ceo say look
look we have to we have to be we have to
be stronger than them
we're not going to let that hurt the
good things we're doing for people is
and you just got to dig deep and say
if you're coming we're coming right back
at you and we're not an easy target
and you just had this part of the
business unfortunately yeah
no i like the way you that you think
about handling that though that yeah
it's like
you just have to rise above it you know
you just have to believe in
what your purpose is what your goal is
you know yeah man and then what you're
doing is putting more good out there
than
you know then uh then these other
systems that are kind of set up not
really to
that are just set up for financial gain
really that's right and then you gotta
have a good legal team and
you tell them go right back at them and
do it you know it's like but anyway
unfortunately that's kind of goes with
the territory we can't let it get us
down we're gonna keep doing it we're
gonna keep creating good things for
people look
for me as just anybody in life you know
whatever you do and we were talking a
lot of entrepreneurship and all this big
stuff and
all this stuff is but whether you're a
teacher whether you're a
welder whether you're whatever you're
doing in life you know
you matter and you matter to people and
you're an example to people like like
you know
my high school coach in my high school
teachers are like some of my biggest
heroes to today
right yeah they influenced me in such a
way and they cared you know to me it
doesn't matter what you do but doing it
and saying let's
bleed the world in a better place you
know everybody thinks that way rather
than get ahead
and i really think that's what america
is all about i think we are that way you
know
i think we are but people remembering
that and keeping that
whatever you do just do it good for
other people too
hey man lean into the good todd graves
thank you so much for joining us man
and you know this was a blast i had a
great time this is cool yeah thanks for
juicing me your son it was a pleasure to
meet him and uh and i'll make uh i'll
look forward to getting
uh one of the best chicken finger meals
here soon
i might be outside right in front of
your pad here really
okay okay i got the truck out here right
here for you i wanted to get it hot and
fresh after we got to have a good talk
and
okay let's go have some chicken that
sounds good thanks todd thank you man
now i'm just floating
on the breeze and i feel like these
leaves i must be
cornerstone
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my heart shine that light on
me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
[Music]
now